I'm Dee Collins under temperature
possible here at West Yorkshire Police
just before 1 o'clock today Joe Cox MP
for battery and spam borough was
attacked in Market Street burst all I am
now very sad to have to report that she
has died as a result of her injuries
before going into further detail I would
like to express our deepest sympathies
to her family and friends at this tragic
time Joe was attacked by a man who
inflicted serious and sadly ultimately
fatal injuries subsequently there was a
further attack on a 77 year old man
nearby who has sustained injuries at a
non-life-threatening shortly afterwards
a man was arrested nearby by local
uniformed police officers weapons
including a firearm have also been
recovered at 1:48 p.m. Joe Cox was
pronounced deceased by a doctor who was
working with a paramedic crew that were
her attending to her serious injuries
this is a very significant investigation
with large numbers of witnesses that
have been spoken to by police at this
time there is a large and significant
crime scene and then there was a large
police presence in the area a full
investigation is underway to establish
the motive
this attack there are specifically
trained officers with Joe's immediate
family who are fully aware of what has
taken place and we would ask the media
to respect their privacy at this very
difficult time
additional officers are working in a
local community this afternoon and
evening in order to provide reassurance
and support to our communities clearly
as this inquiry is in a very early stage
and we have an individual under arrest
we are not in a position to discuss any
motive at this time
we are not looking for anyone else in
connection with this incident at present
I'm mark burns Williamson the police and
crime Commissioner for West Yorkshire my
thoughts and prayers are with Jill's
family at this time I've worked closely
with Jo since she was elected and am
deeply shocked that such a talented
young woman has been so senselessly
attacked and killed whilst working in
their constituency and serving her
community this is a truly shocking
incident but I want to try and reassure
communities that our information is that
this is a localized incident albeit one
that has a much wider impact I must
stress that investigations are ongoing
under man has been arrested and we need
to let the police do their job in
understanding exactly what has happened
that's led to this usually tragic
incident and channel all of our thoughts
into supporting the families and
communities affected at this site thank
you